- We are still hanging
out with Eric Stonestreet.
Give it up!
- Still here. Still here.
Haven't left yet.
- Haven't left.
We will not let him leave yet.
- Been asked to leave,
and I'm not leaving.
- Nope. Nope.
I'm just keeping you here.
Eric's new show is called "Domino Masters"
and we don't have time
to set up 8,000 dominoes.
So instead we thought
now would be a good time
for a new, fast, friendly competition,
called "Domin-Know Your Enemy."
Do you get it?
(upbeat music)
- Yeah.
♪ Domin-know your enemy ♪
- I'm throwing stuff. I'm throwing stuff.
Okay, the Voice of God,
why is there nothing in here?
What kind of game is this?
(audience laughing)
What is this TV magic?
- Why don't I have cups?
- We should, Justin, is there wine?
I'm just saying.
Okay. Voice of God, could
you moderate this challenge?
- [Voice Of God] Well,
I would love to, Kelly,
and hello, Eric.
How you doing?
- Hello. Good, God.
- [Voice Of God] Yeah, you
enjoying those corn nuts
in your dressing room.
- Yes. Thank you so much.
[Voice Of God] Mm-hmm?
Maybe make me a balloon
animal after the show.
Anyway-
- Of course, God.
Anything for you.
- Now, here's what's about
to go down.
Now, You both are gonna
take turns guessing
if a statement that I read
about the other person
is true or a false.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Voice Of God] Now, once
I've read the statement,
you get to ask the other
person one question related
to the statement,
but not directly about it.
So if I say,
"Kelly, once hid in Dolly
Parton's dressing room."
And, Eric, you can ask
Kelly something like
"Have you ever seen Dolly Parton perform?"
but you can't ask
"Did you ever hide under the table
in Dolly Parton's dress room?"
Is that true, Kelly? Did you do that?
- Nope.
- [Voice Of God] Okay.
- Now it's a challenge,
personally.
- Yeah, okay.
- Yeah, well, we'll see.
- I'm gonna see her soon.
So maybe I'll do it.
- [Voice Of God] I know
all, and it's true.
I'm gonna be the judge on if
a question is allowed, okay.
So now once you have your
final true or false answer,
you're gonna hit the
button, and lock it in.
You got it?
- Okay.
- Okay. Okay.
- [Voice Of God] Okay, here we go.
Here's the first one.
When Eric Stonestreet was younger,
he almost gave up acting to
become a concierge butcher.
- When you raised pigs on
your farm, who took them to,
you know?
- Their maker?
- Yeah.
- God knows.
(Eric laughing)
We would take them
to the butcher shop.
Well, not the butcher
shop, but the meat market.
And I'll tell you a little side note.
I was always a little unhappy
with how happy they seemed to be
when we took them there.
- Oh. So dark!
The guy always seemed a
little bit too anxious.
- Oh no!
I was like,
"I don't wanna take him
there anymore, Dad."
- I don't wanna take him, Daddy.
You're like, okay, I think you did.
I think you would've been a butcher.
I think true.
- That is correct.
It is true.
- I knew it!
(bell dinging)
- [Voice Of God] That's right.
- You were stuttering.
- That's a point for Kelly.
- I was gonna call it "Stonestreet Meats."
(Kelly laughing)
- That's right. That's right.
- That's awesome.
Eric, not only handled
luggage and made reservations,
but he delivered pork butt to your room.
(Kelly laughing)
So that's...
Okay. Now, here we go.
This one is for you, Eric.
- It is true?
- [Voice Of God] Okay?
Kelly was once told
Whataburger was out of burgers,
so she went to the
store, bought some beef,
and brought it back.
Is that true or false, Eric?
- It's a friendly thing.
- Well, I know you're from Texas
and I know Whataburger is the-
- Interesting.
- In-N-Out of Texas.
I find it better than In-N-Out.
- We just became best friends.
- So the answer is true.
(buzzer ringing)
(Kelly laughing)
- The answer is half true.
Not true.
- I'm sorry. It is false.
(buzzer buzzing)
- The answer,
this is where they got you.
Because, this is tricky,
because I did go to Whataburger
after a night of dancing
and we were dying laughing,
'cause our designated driver
was getting us burgers,
whatever late at night.
And they ran out of burgers.
And I was like, "You
don't run out of burgers
when you're Whata!
It's in the title."
- So why am I
not getting true?
- Because I did not go get the meat though
and bring it back.
- That's right. That's right.
- That is a bull (beep) question.
(Kelly laughing)
- [Kelly] He should get half the point.
- [Voice Of God] Now, so Kelly,
you'd say you have a
beef with Whataburger?
- I have a beef with, I like,
it's dad jokes all day.
- Okay. Let's move on.
- I got this.
- Let's move on.
All right?
(Eric faintly speaking)
Here is your next question.
- Okay.
- [Voice Of God] Eric visited "The Voice"
and took pictures in
Kelly Clarkson's chair.
- Have you ever been to "The Voice?"
- Yes.
- I don't remember you
being there on my seasons.
- Oh, did the show just
start when you got on there?
- Yes it did.
- I know. I agree with that.
- No, I-
- [Voice Of God] So would
you say true or false Kelly?
- I don't think you ever sat in my chair.
I think if you had the choice
you might sit in my chair,
but maybe Blake's, I don't know.
I'm gonna say no.
I'm gonna say false.
- That is correct.
- False. Oh, shoot.
(buzzer ringing)
False.
- [Voice Of God] It is false.
And that is another point to Kelly.
(audience applauding)
- It is false!
- It is false,
- [Voice Of God] That is right.
- I'm amazing!
- You're correct.
- Have you been to "The Voice?"
What season?
- I have been to "The Voice"
and I sat in Blake's chair.
- I told you!
You probably would sit in-
- I know!
You've been given the answers, God!
- [Kelly] No, no! I just
figured you'd be like,
"I wanna sit in Blake's."
I figured-
- Well, no.
It was the closest one.
(Kelly laughing)
- [Voice Of God] You better
watch yourself, Eric.
Or you're gonna be back playing
birthday parties as a clown.
Now calm down.
- I'm sorry, God.
- [Voice Of God] All right.
Here's your next question?
Kelly wrote her hit song
"Underneath the Tree" in 20 minutes
because she was hungry
and her sushi was waiting.
- What state were you in
when you wrote that song?
- That is a solid question. Wow!
I was in California.
- So then I'm gonna go true.
- Yes!
It's true.
- It is true
and you have a point, Eric.
(bell dinging)
- I'm like-
- That was a good question.
- I'm like if you're in Texas,
you're not waiting on sushi.
- Oh my God.
I totally thought you're gonna be like,
this is unbelievable.
And then that question you asked,
I was like, that was a smart question.
- Yeah, I'm a detective.
- You are a competitive man.
- [Voice Of God] Okay, this
is your final question.
This is for all the points.
This one is worth 50 points.
- Mm!
- Okay?
- What?
- That's a lot of points.
- [Voice Of God] At his
audition for "Modern Family."
- [Kelly] Oh God.
- [Voice Of God] Eric took off his shirt
and danced to "Kiss" by Prince.
Is that true or false?
Kelly, you have one question you can ask.
- Oh my God. I pray to God it's true.
(audience laughing)
(Eric singing "Kiss" by Prince)
- [Kelly] Oh my God, I hope it's true.
- Okay. I'm gonna have a question.
Okay.
(Eric singing "Kiss" by Prince)
- That's it.
- So wait. Okay, wait.
I got to have a question.
Your question was so good.
Okay.
I'm not even ask the question.
I just really pray to God it's true.
I'm gonna say it's true.
(buzzer ringing)
- False.
(buzzer buzzing)
- [Voice Of God] It is false. I'm sorry.
- I am disappointed in you.
- But let's do it now.
- I am actually,
(audience cheering)
I am actually disappointed.
- I know.
- I was like, that would've been amazing!
- So Eric is the winner.
- Thank you!
- Okay, okay.
- Thank you, God.
- All right!
- Big fan, big fan.
And because Eric knew me
better than I knew him,
Eric's photo,
you will not only have been in his chair,
you will now be on this
disgusting wall that is his
and I resent it
and it's called "The Blake
Shelton Wall Of Champions
Who Beat Kelly Clarkson."
- Awesome!
- [Kelly] You get hang
to hang on that wall.
- Thank you to Blake!
- Thanks for playing, Eric.
- Thank you, Kelly.